this is a production of Cornell
University
so as Carl just mentioned the really the
steps to applying aerial phenotyping are
to first create a flight plan we use
litchi in order to do that then on the
day of the of the flight
you should capture an image standard we
use an image standard that comes with
the camera this mic sense camera then on
the day of the flight you fly obviously
and you you capture the images then you
can then you need to stitch those images
into a complete ortho mosaic so that's
the complete image of the field and then
finally you need to be able to assign
plot polygons and be able to actually
use these images either for extracting
mene mene pixel values which go into say
NDVI
or using these images for in in machine
learning
so the
where we're using is is the same as as
what Carl just presented we use a
different drone but it's similar we have
this DJI hexacopter and then this mica
sense v fan camera and it the the five
bands correspond to blue green red afar
red and then a near infrared and those
bands coincide with where chlorophyll is
is reflective and absorb absorptive and
since chlorophyll is the primary means
of production for the plan we're hoping
we were we were hoping that this would
be a a good good bands to measure I'm
presenting today just a single aerial a
single field experiment that's part of
the genomes to Fields consortium so
genome so Fields is a a multi location
multi-year hybrid and inbred evaluation
and so here I'm just showing from 2017
and yh2 but I do have from 2015 and 2016
as well and working on 2018 2019 so in
2017 for this experiment we had seven
flights nick has more collected these so
you see the different dates that we flew
on throughout the growing season five
hundred plots total 232 hybrids then
using this image breed that I've been
working on which is part of the breed
base database out of Lucas Mueller's lab
I could segment the plot individual
plots and then have them saved in the
database against their you know the
field design and
and what would the hybrid that was
planted there and and so on and so
looking at or calculating NDVI and ndre
these are two vegetative indices NDVI
uses near infrared and red well ndre
uses near infrared and the far red band
we see that they're all highly
correlated across days after planting
and if you look at the bottom row at 91
and 106 days after planting there's a
point for its 0.5 phenotypic correlation
to yield so to try to improve these
correlations we can try threshold assail
or any kind of background
so here the the threshold I applied was
just to drop the twenty drop the lowest
25% of pixels and so you can see I mean
visually it looks to be doing what was
intended and then calculating these in
the same indices on the thresholded
images improves the correlation here
like in ng re we see 0.6 at 91 days
after planting just show kind of showing
how he'll distributes over over this so
it tends to cluster at the higher ends
of these vegetative indices so of course
since this is only phenotypic and we
want it we need to calculate
heritability xand and improve our models
here but what I'm excited about is to
try using CN NS to
directly learn the features from the
images so as Travis kind of showed the
other day but there's a CNN has an
architecture and this architecture
defines the different filters and
different layers in it the good thing
about cnn's is you can just use some
off-the-shelf and so here the input that
I'm feeding into it is a kind of a
montage of four different images so in
the top left is the art red green blue
then the top right have the near
infrared and red and bottom-left
near-infrared and the far red and then
bottom left is just a near-infrared
threshold and so normalizing and
centering these images before for
putting them in is a good idea and so
just showing some preliminary results
that came out of this training training
this CNN on images from 92 and 105 days
after planting from 2015 and yh2 and
then so training it on that data and
then testing it with images from 91 and
106 days after planting in 2017 and yh2
we see a r-squared of 0.45 and
to point out that there were many of
plots where we couldn't get grain yield
so that's this blue of these blue values
at the bottom where it was predicted but
we we don't have true values and moving
in the future just want to say that the
CNN isn't taking into account any
genetic relationships but there are ways
that we can try incorporating like a
genetic relationship into that and when
I say thank everyone especially Nick San
Antonio and Nick Cosmo so the question
was if I if I used if I retrained the
CNN or if I used pre trained weights
I just retrained the whole thing and I
these were the initial weights were
random so the question is if I've used
if I've thought about using an
autoencoder to train the architecture
and no I have not but I'd be interested
to try that actually they even
the two days that could be put together
quite interesting
okay thanks well what might be like the
effect strongly looking from above
just like variation structure yeah so
the question is if if the structure more
the spatial arrangement of the plot is
is really driving the correlation
instead of the genotype or and I think
there's especially for the CNN there's
that's probably what's happening like so
we'll have to have to be careful about
that
but for like the NDB I or ndre that's
probably not playing into it as much do
you intend to build any more traditional
linear models across longitudinal time
points to try to predict your end of
season phenotypes yeah yeah so question
is if we're planning to use linear
models to model it longitudinally and
yet I've definitely when I look at like
random regressions and I'm the light
yeah but haven't you did you showed that
the image that you were analyzing was
definitive four quadrants with
difference.i ratios or differences right
between the different wavelengths why is
that better and just having each
wavelength in there sick in their own
image well doesn't that subtraction is
my simple and could be done by this in
in itself
yeah good question so the it's why the
input is montage of the different
spectra and
so the the reason I think is well I
guess I should try it both ways but I've
only tried it this way and I I don't
know I don't have a good answer but I
think joining it having it so that
you're not making multiple predictions
on the same plot I think maybe that's
beneficial whereas the CNN is only
learning in from its that's its only
source of information like so yeah but I
don't have a good answer this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu